[MUSIC PLAYING]
[HEART BEATING]
JASON SILVA: So there's
a fascinating Ted talk
by the brilliant
Esther Perel, author
of "Mating in
Captivity," where she
explores the secret to desire
in long-term relationships.
Because this, of course,
is the holy grail.
Falling in love is easy.
The honeymoon period,
anybody would take that ride.
But what happens upon
the moment that routine
becomes part of your
reality, the person
you're with every single day.
How do you retain that
passion, that fire?
This is again the mystery
of long-term desire.
And Ester Perel, she went
around the world asking couples,
when are you most
drawn to your partner?
And what she found
across the board,
everyone said the same thing.
They found their partner
the most attractive when
they were able to see their
partner as a self sustaining
entity.
It's this idea that they
were able to perceive
their partner the way that
other people perceive them,
as a complete individual; as
a complete self-sustaining
person.
Not the other half of
you, but as a solid whole.
And so this idea that attraction
requires a kind of distance,
that even desire requires
a crossing over, she says.
And I thought that was
absolutely brilliant,
because how can incorporate
that into our own relationships?
How can we create space between
us and the ones we love,
so that we can reclaim
that crossing over?
So that we can see them as
that self-sustaining entity,
and fully appreciate them
as the fully rounded,
complete being that they are.
I think she's on to
something, that Esther Perel,
and for that reason, I
think she's brilliant.
And I think everybody
should watch that TED Talk.
Because If we could
hack the secret
to desire in the
long term, that could
solve a lot of our problems.
[MUSIC PLAYING]